[Applaus]
[Musik]
das donnern der russischen kanonen in
der ukraine übertönt dieser tage so
manch andere entwicklungen welche mit
ihnen jedoch eng zusammenhängen und
langfristig sogar weitaus stärkere
auswirkungen auf die weltordnung dieses
jahrhunderts haben wird denn auch dann
wenn der russische bär gebändigt seien
dort lauert der viel größere und
wichtigere chinesische drachen schon um
die ecke aber keine angst wir hier bei
visual politik lassen uns nicht durch
ablenkungsmanöver verwirrend und halten
steht die augen offen um euch auf alle
wichtigen entwicklungen hinzuweisen
deswegen müssen wir uns heute unbedingt
nach australien und südkorea begeben
[Musik]
gut was haben diese zwei länder die mehr
als 6000 kilometer voneinander entfernt
sind gemein manche werden wahrscheinlich
sagen die usa als verbündeten
schließlich sind sowohl südkorea als
auch australien strategische verbündete
der amerikanischen supermacht beides
sind wichtige allianzen verschenken
beide sind unverzichtbare verbündete für
den einfluss der amerikaner in der
asiatisch-pazifischen region die zum
wichtigsten knotenpunkt der
weltwirtschaft geworden ist
[Musik]
das ist übrigens nicht das einzige was
sie gemein haben im koreakrieg gift die
australier zusammen mit den südkoreanern
um die invasion des kommunistischen
regimes in nordkorea zu verhindern
welches wiederum von mehr als einer
millionen chinesische soldaten
unterstützt wurde seitdem gehören sie
beide zu den politischen
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen block
der von den vereinigten staaten von
amerika angeführt wird
aber in den letzten 20 jahren hat die
ankunft eines neuen großen politischen
und ökonomischen akteurs große
unterschiede in den beziehungen zwischen
diesen beiden ländern offenbart ich
spreche natürlich von der sogenannten
volksrepublik china
mit dem wachsenden wirtschaftlichen
politischen und militärischen einfluss
chinas verändert sich alles in diesem
teil der welt und deswegen müssen wir
uns genau die gleiche frage stellen die
vier führenden politikern in der ganzen
welt auf der seele brennt was sollen wir
mit china bloß machen die weltwirtschaft
hat sich in starke abhängigkeit vom
reich der mitte begeben doch sein herz
verschiedenen pink über den dass ich ihm
geld darauf befindliche neue china durch
innere wie äußere konflikte die es nicht
gewinnen kann der sie auf krassen
fehleinschätzungen basieren er hat das
noch verlogene putin russland zu seinem
wasser innenstadt gemacht einem
anhängsel und proxy chinas über welchen
er in der ukraine einen schnellen
stellvertreterkrieg gegen die nato
führen wollte der jedoch noch schneller
außer kontrolle geraten ist so langsam
merkt man auch in peking dass man auf
den falschen proxy gesetzt hatte einen
der sein versprechen eines reibungslosen
blitz kriegs nicht einhalten konnte und
seinen bündnispartner nun immer tiefer
mit in die blutige lachen ist eines
brutalen vernichtungskrieg hineinzieht
und bisher gab es keine einheitliche
antwort der aufstieg chinas zur
supermacht dies viele außenpolitische
modelle ins leere laufen doch genau
diese unentschiedenheit könnte peking
ungewollt mit seinem plazet für putins
angriffskrieg entschieden haben und zwar
gegen sich australien und südkorea sind
gute beispiele
zwei länder die jahrzehntelang zum
selben block gehört haben dann aber ganz
unterschiedliche wege im umgang mit
china eingeschlagen haben eine trennung
der grenzen gesetzt sind denn in
wahrheit in suhl den südkoreanern als
auf den australien weitgehend die hände
gebunden warum nun lass uns das mal
checken
etwa 30 prozent der australischen
exporte sind für den chinesischen markt
bestimmt das ist sogar mehr als der
anteil von südkorea mit 25 prozent
außerdem kommt der großteil der
australischen touristen aus china im
fall von südkorea haben im jahr 2019
also von rona 6 millionen chinesen das
land besucht das entspricht fast 35
prozent der gesamtbevölkerung des
gastlandes australien wiederum wird
jährlich von fast 1,5 millionen
chinesischen touristen besucht und auch
im zusammenhang mit ausländischen
investitionen stecken marktanteil des
asiatischen riesen kontinuierlich
ja es gibt leute die das alte wachsende
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit bezeichnet
und ob das nun stimmt oder nicht man
kann nicht davon weg sehen dass solche
zahlen im allgemeinen einen starken
einfluss auf die außenpolitik eines
landes haben allerdings ist es natürlich
die eine sache einfluss zu haben aber
eine ganz andere sich direkt in die
politik eines landes einzumischen in
beziehungen zwischen australien und
china sind auf dem tiefsten punkt ihrer
geschichte angelangt sagt der ehemalige
botschafter und obwohl china bereist und
größten handelspartner australiens
geworden ist hat sich das land der
koalas und kängurus trotzdem weiterhin
eng an den regionalen interessen
washingtons orientiert im mai 2002 20
finden in australien parlamentswahlen
statt und angesichts der chinesisch
russischen kriegs achse passt
mittlerweile zwischen beiden großen
oppositionsparteien in sachen china
politik kein blatt papier mehr war die
australische labour partei bisher so
nachsicht gegenüber peking bereit und
wenigstens so eine stärkung der
gemeinsamen geschäftsbeziehungen sind
auch bei ihr jegliche anzeichen einer
erwiesenen politik verflogen im
wahlkampf wetteifern labour und die
konservativen darum wer am schärfsten
gegen china schließt der konservative
australische premierminister scott
morrison sagte dass seine regierung
harte sanktionen gegen hierfür würde
falls china militärische ausrüstung an
russland nicht dann würde er betonte
dass jeder schritt chinas trost als
bewaffnet oder russland beim umgehen der
verhängten wirtschaftssanktionen zu
helfen eine abscheulichkeit darstellen
würde dabei muss man sich in erinnerung
rufen dass australien kaum
wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit der ukraine
unterhält in china jedoch viel zu
verlieren hat trotzdem hat es die
zeichen der zeit erkannt und sich
absolut kategorisch ja in australien ist
der zug wird peking definitiv abgefahren
aber was ist mit südkorea nun südkorea
vor jahrzehntelang eine ganz andere
strategie als australien in diesem video
webseite ansehen welche
unterschiedlichen wege diese beiden
wichtigen verbündeten
in bezug auf china eingeschlagen haben
sie stehen exemplarisch für viele andere
länder auf diesen planeten die
angesichts der jetzigen zeiten wenn sie
nach langer zeit farbe bekennen werden
und die gretchenfrage am ende wird
lauten welche strategie würdest du
unterstützen wenn du an roter sees ist
welche farbe würdest du bekennen bevor
wir jedoch loslegen müssen wir uns bei
unserem sponsor aufschlag bedanken der
dieses video möglich gemacht hat jörg
ist ein sehr sicheres vpn dass weder
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lockt der in
anonymität und sicherheit im netz sind
ein immer kostbares gut und wir alle
sollten so viel wie möglich dafür tun
ist bietet darüber hinaus unzählige
sicher heißt es zum beispiel queen web
dass alle cookies popups und auch
fortgeschrittene identifizierungs und
nahversorgungs mechanismen von denen man
oft gar nicht sicher braucht und die
damit verbundenen gefahren beseitigt
natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auf
webseiten und internet dienste zugreifen
die in dem land in dem er gerade sei
nicht verfügbar sind ohne zensur und
kuhglocken ob daheim oder im urlaub
fliegt und andere streaming dienste die
ihre inhalte nur in den usa anbieten von
europa aus nutzen mit surf kein problem
aber nicht nur das wenn nur ein solcher
kommt da könnt ihr alle eure geräte
informieren registrieren handys
notebooks und sogar euren smart tvs
deckt wirklich alle arten von geräten ab
ihr bekommt damit einen lückenlosen
schutz so und wenn ihr den rabattcode
politik.de angibt bekommt ihr von surf
schlag auch noch einen rabatt in höhe
von 83 prozent und obendrein den ersten
drei monate gratis dazu den link zu
diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt als surf stadt
und kreis damit weise die auch uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des ejc
betten links den ich euch jedenfalls den
die beschreibung gepackt habe so und nun
lasst uns schnell wieder zum thema
dieses videos zurückkommen und zur frage
welche politik würdest du gegenüber
china unterstützen also los geht's
[Musik]
keine rücksicht mehr auf peking
wenn man noch vor ein paar jahren nach
einem westlichen land gefragt hätte dass
ich verdammt schlecht mit china versteht
wäre australien dabei sicher niemandem
eingefallen das land hat 125 millionen
einwohner von denen 1,2 millionen
menschen chinesischer herkunft sind
regelmäßig kommen sowohl tausende von
zahlenden studierenden als auch viel
kapital aus den asiatischen riesen land
australien hat so eine wirtschaftliche
beziehungen mit der volksrepublik china
dass viele analysten nichts vögeln es
stark abhängig zu bezeichnen aber die
beziehungen zwischen den vereinigten
staaten und australien die schon
historisch gesehen die besten freunde in
der internationalen politik sind erleben
gerade einen zweiten honeymoon seit
barack obama einen er 2011 in einer rede
im australischen parlament das land als
die amerikanische neuausrichtung nach
asien genannt hat ein beispiel dafür ist
die errichtung von zwei wichtigen
stützpunkt im pazifik und im norden
australiens für die us luftwaffe und die
us-marine dies ist natürlich eine art
von entwicklungen die peking überhaupt
nicht leiden kann
[Musik]
besonders anschließend im jahr 2021 die
australier eine absprache lieferung von
atomgetriebenen u-boot mit den usa und
großbritannien gemacht haben mit diesen
attributen können sie quasi vor chinas
haustür spazieren fahren aber über den
august diehl haben wir schon in anderen
video gesprochen welches ich dir
natürlich verlinken werde vergiss bitte
auch nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren
damit du zukunft keines unserer videos
mit passt starke die durch august wurde
im grunde genommen eine zeitenwende im
pazifik eingeleitet weil ich in den lauf
der weltgeschichte verändern könnte
daher sollten wir die hintergründe und
die vorgeschichte ganzen entwicklungen
die zu diesem bündnis führte genau unter
die lupe nehmen die sache ist nämlich
dass die australier immer größere
vorbehalte gegen das grabschen der
chinesischen fangarme hatten
und sie finden ist absolut nicht
plötzlich wenn chinesische unternehmen
wichtige australischen sachwerte
übernehmen transaktionen wie die
99-jährige verachtung des hafens n damen
an das chinesische unternehmen land
bridgeclub für 380 millionen dollar im
jahr 2015 werden heute als bedrohung der
nationalen sicherheit angesehen und es
sieht auch so aus als ob chinesische
unternehmen scheinbar davon besessen
sind die kontrolle über wichtige
infrastruktur in australien zu
übernehmen hinzu gesellen sich
zahlreiche skandale australische
politiker und geschäftsleute mit
verdächtigen verbindungen zur
chinesischen regierung die gemeinsam mit
dem machtantritt von trump einen
explosiven cocktail dargestellt haben
der das misstrauen und die vorbehalte
australier gegenüber china in die höhe
schnellen ließ deshalb wird mittlerweile
praktisch jede einigermaßen wichtige
chinesische investitionen in australien
einer intensiven politischen und
sozialen musterung unterzogen
[Musik]
es wurde sogar so schlimm das ist anfang
2000 20 und 21 zu einer art
handelskriegs zwischen australien jahr
kamen in dem wir strafzölle
sonderabgaben boykotte und sogar
verleumdungskampagnen voll von beats und
betrügerischen fotomontagen erlebt haben
das alles ist sehr melodramatisch fast
schon wie eine lateinamerikanische
seifenoper wollt ihr ein paar konkrete
beispiele bitteschön staatliche medien
berichten dass china die kürzungen der
australischen kohle importe formalisiert
china verhält bis zu 200 prozent soll
auf australischen wein
australien verklagt china wegen gästen
zählen vor der whu peking verhängte
zelle in höhe von 80 prozent auf
getreide nachdem sich die bilateralen
beziehungen verschlechtert hatten wie du
dir vorstellen kannst haben diese
kristalle nichts mit wirtschaftlichen
problemen zu tun sondern eher mit
politischen und in der tat im jahr 2020
durch liegt das verhältnis zwischen
pickeln und canberra eine phase
besonders großer spannung
[Musik]
die australische regierung gehörte zu
denjenigen die sphinx politik am
stärksten kritisiert hatten und im
zusammenhang mit den ereignissen
konkretisierte die australische
regierung pekings machtübernahme in der
stadt besonders scharf und als ob das
noch nicht genug wäre verweigerte die
regierung auf australischem boden den
aufbau von 5 g netzwerken durch
chinesische unternehmen wie huawei
darüber hinaus hat die australische
regierung den bau künstlicher
chinesische inseln im südchinesischen
meer verurteilt aber die streitigkeiten
zwischen den beiden ländern enden hier
noch lange nicht sein die noch viel viel
weiter die beziehungen zwischen
australien und china das sind man sich
nach dem provokativen tweet eines hohen
beamten der kommunistischen partei auf
dem tiefpunkt in diesem tief
veröffentlichte ein hochrangiger beamter
des chinesischen aussenministeriums eine
fotomontage die einen angeblich
australischen soldaten mit einem
blutigen messer in der hand zeigt der
gerade dabei ist einem afghanischen
jungen mit einem lamm im arm die kehle
durchzuschneiden
klingt ziemlich verrückt nicht wahr die
nachricht dazu lautete wie folgt
schockierende ermordung von afghanischen
zivilisten und gefangenen durch
australische soldaten
wir verurteilen solche taten aufs
schärfste und fordern dass sie zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden li jiao
stellvertretender direktor der
informationsabteilung des
außenministeriums der volksrepublik
china
dieser trägt selbstverständlich auf
allen ebenen australischen politik die
alarmglocken läuten lassen
[Musik]
die beziehungen zwischen peking und
kemberger erreichten einen neuen
tiefpunkt und das obwohl die beiden
länder gerade erst den neuen regional
comprehensive economic partnership
agreement beigetreten waren das 15
länder in der region integriert es ist
natürlich so dass all dieser fonds dafür
gesorgt haben dass die meinung der
australier über das reich der mitte
total in den keller gerutscht ist ein
beispiel laut einer studie von pew
research aus dem oktober 2020 haben ein
80 prozent der australier ein schlechtes
bild von china und 79 prozent glauben
nicht dass man schlittschuh hängen mit
seiner internationalen politik vertrauen
kann wie gesagt australien hat sehr enge
wirtschaftliche beziehungen zu china
aber trotzdem was sich die australische
regierung eindeutig dafür entschieden
und sich mit den vereinigten staaten für
das politische konzept des westens
einzutreten und alle exzesse der
regierung von sheikh aktiv anzuprangern
und diese strategie des idealismus legte
down under und würden schon an den tag
als die europäische union und länder wie
südkorea nach einem opportunistischen
pragmatismus nachhingen gut und zu
welchem ergebnis wird das ganze genau
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an
[Musik]
südkoreas feine balance akt
wenn man sich die beziehungen zwischen
südkorea und china ansieht damit man
eine sehr gemischte bilanz vor china hat
sich von einem erklärten feind südkoreas
in korea krieg in den darauffolgenden
drei jahrzehnten zu dessen wichtigsten
handelspartner entwickelt der scharen
von touristen ins land schickt in den
korridoren des blauen hauses des
südkoreanischen konzerns von weißen
hauswand davon überzeugt dass es besser
ist sich zu schauen als riskiert einen
politischen und vielleicht auch
handelspolitischen konflikt auszulösen
der für südkorea sehr schädlich sein
könnte und noch mehr das ist alles
andere als die spekulation ist südkorea
hat war ein paar jahren eine
vorgeschmack davon bekommen welche
auswirkungen ein chinesischer wutanfall
haben kann china führte südkorea 2017
eine menge schmerzen zu und der grund
aufgrund nordkoreanischer
interkontinentalraketen test im jahr
2017 entstanden große spannungen auf der
koreanischen halbinsel
und mit zustimmung haben daraufhin die
vereinigten staaten dem dfb die
raketenschild in südkorea stationiert
peking rastete damals aus weil es
glaubte dass die leistungsstarken os
radar jede bewegung seiner armee an der
ostküste aufspüren könnten als resultat
kam ein massiver boykott gegen südkorea
plötzlich konsumierten die chinesen
keines südkoreanischen produkte mehr der
chinesische tourismus ist südkorea kam
zum stillstand und viele lokale
unternehmen erlittenen verlusten in
millionenhöhe
wir mussten gar um finanzielle
unterstützung bei der regierung bitten
viele koreanische unternehmen die in
china geschäfte machen wurden
schikaniert insbesondere die lotto
klären konnte platz für die installation
von die echte idee zur verfügung
gestellt wurde sogar autos koreanischer
marken wurden beschädigt oder zerstört
und obwohl die in südkorea von der
ehemaligen präsidentin part genehmigt
wurde fand die installation unter ihrer
nachfolger muti innenstadt und er hat
diese nicht nur nicht gestoppt sondern
sogar jede neue batterie einzelnen
persönlich genehmigt
aber das war's dann auch schon mehr
stirn hast die nun regierung china ist
geboten seitdem hat südkorea gegenüber
ihrem asiatischen riesen nachbarn sogar
andere töne angeschlagen und wenn man
die südkoreanische position mit der
australischen vergleich von der wir
vorhin gesprochen haben dann hat die
damalige südkoreanische regierung
absolut nichts gegen die chinesischen
übergriffe in hongkong gesagt
[Musik]
genau so haben sie weder fragen über den
ursprung des corona virus sichergestellt
noch höher weil daran gehindert in ihrem
land zu errichten oder den bau
künstliche inseln im südchinesischen
meer kritisiert und nicht nur das korea
hat sich deren streams präsidentschaft
in der frage des handelskrieg zwischen
den usa und china heraus gehalten und
ist nie so weit gegangen die
außenpolitik des asiatischen riesen zu
kommentieren abgesehen natürlich vom
typischen wir sind über die situation
sehr besorgt nun stellt sich die frage
wie sich diese unabhängigkeit erklärt
ist südkorea nicht einer der engsten
verbündeten der vereinigten staaten in
der welt und ihr wichtigster verbündeter
in ostasien nun ebenfalls südkorea es
kommen noch weitere faktoren ins spiel
die man sich unbedingt ansehen was
jedenfalls ist um die regierung juli in
ging das problem der nach es so nennen
kann ist dass fast alle großen
südkoreanischen konzernen nicht nur
große geschäfte auf dem chinesischen
markt machen sondern auch eine große
zahl ihrer fabriken dort haben
[Musik]
und obwohl einige hersteller wie samsung
und lg in den letzten jahren fabriken in
anderen ländern wie zum beispiel vietnam
errichtet haben über dessen rivalität
mit china der bald in einem eigenen
video berichten werden ist die
abhängigkeit von china bei der
herstellung südkoreanische produkte
immer noch enorm mit anderen worten so
lässt sich im klaren darüber dass das
regime von vielen dingen zölle und
beschränkungen gegen südkorea verhängt
wird ähnlich oder sogar noch schlimmer
als die repressalien die es bereits
gegen australien gab wenn man hier
verärgert sie wollen die gefährdung der
globalen geschäfte große koreanischen
unternehmen verhindern denn das wäre ein
zu großes risiko trotzdem so einfach ist
das alles nicht die südkoreanische
regierung ist zwischen drei variablen
gefangen wie schwer zu vereinbaren sind
der wirtschaft ihre allianz mit den usa
und der öffentlichen meinung genauso wie
die australier hält auch das
südkoreanische volk nicht viel von china
oder schwingen
laut umfragen sind los trotz der
südkoreaner der meinung dass ihr land
eine bessere beziehung zu china haben
sollte als du den usa und nur 17 prozent
der meinung das ist ein gleichwertiges
verhältnis zu china und den usa haben
sollte war auch im grunde die politik
der abgewählten regierung hinauslief
außerdem können laut umfragen 83 prozent
des südkoreaners shipping nicht leiden
und 76 prozent haben einen negativen
eindruck von china als land
[Musik]
die alte südkoreanische regierung von
moon hat sich wird ganz anderer
maßnahmen entschieden als der
australische premierminister scott
morrison und damit nicht unbedingt die
meinung der eigenen bevölkerung
vertreten so und jetzt kommt der große
platz ist ihre neutrale haltung
gegenüber den immer aggressiver
auftretenden china hat muss partei nun
die wiederwahl gekostet bei der
präsidentschaftswahl am noten märz 2022
schlug der china kritische konservative
oppositionskandidat die jungs schub mio
sein widersacher von der demokratischen
partei der monde erden sollte
ausschlaggebend dürfte auch gewesen sein
dass peking moskau so lange freie hand
bei ihrem angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine ließ damit brach nämlich auch
eine ganz neue ära des südkoreanischen
beziehungen an der neu gewählte
präsident will die beziehungen zu china
neu gestalten und zu den usa weiter
stärken analysten erwarten dass südkorea
dem ende pazifischen handelsabkommen
washingtons beitritt und eine
schlüsselrolle in einer neuen auf die
usa ausgerichteten lieferkette spielen
wird das gemeinsame ziel die
abhängigkeit der weltwirtschaft von
china zu reduzieren
aber das ist schon wieder ein thema für
ein eigenes video also aber nicht
vergessen ausland zerbricht in der
ukraine also nicht nur sein eigenes
sondern auch ganz ganz viel chinesisches
porzellan
[Musik]
hiergegen hat mit putin auf den falschen
proxy gesetzt statt den geplanten
ablenkungsmanöver droht sein krieg nun
zur globalen ist alle für beide
diktaturen zu werden gegen die sich nun
immer mehr zuvor neutral eingestellten
länder wenden und damit kommen wir
zurück zu der frage die ich so beginnt
des videos gestellt habe welche position
es besser sollten wir umgang mit china
wirtschaftlichen pragmatismus bevorzugen
wie es die alte regierung südkoreas tat
oder sollten die westlichen demokratien
die chinesische regierung zur rede
stellen wie es australien in den letzten
jahren getan hat und jetzt auf die neue
regierung südkoreas tun wird was ist
wichtiger billige preise und der
schnelle euro oder wirtschaftliche
unabhängigkeit und selbstbestimmung wie
stellt sich dann dank dem risiko einer
hohen abhängigkeit von china hatte es
eine strategie dagegen oder fährt ist
weiterhin nur auf sicht wie im falle
russlands schreibt uns bitte in die
kommentare was er darüber denkt wir sind
auf die angeregte diskussion schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat was jahr gibt es mit
einem lifetime und freunde und vergesst
nicht dass aber mit glück keines unserer
videos nicht zu verpassen natürlich
freut auch jederzeit über eine spende
von euch mit der er uns helfen dieses
projekt weiterzuführen dem paper link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]